The last time anybody saw me in a Stormtrooper outfit...
...was when we rescued the princess on the Death Star.
So, I'm getting suited up in my Stormtrooper gear,...
...about ready to hit Hollywood Boulevard for "Force for Change."
This is your last chance to win tickets to the premiere.
You get to meet the whole cast.
Wow!
Do I get to go to the movie in your outfit?
You could...
Listen, if you want it, you can have it.
It's not that comfortable; I can't see very well.
Oh boy!
You can win four tickets to the premiere.
Have a great day!
Would you like to meet Mark Hamill?
I'd love to!
Hey, that's the man, besides you.
Who would you most like to meet at the premiere?
No, not Han Solo.
Mark Hamilton.
Mark Hamilton?
I've been in love with that man.
Do you have any power converters?
Just donate ten dollars.
You don't wanna be a bad guy, do you?